hello there obi-wan kenobi has just
dropped its finale and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
all the easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed last week had rokin
and the rebels fleeing into space whilst
riva remained behind to try and strike
down vader this backfired and like the
grand inquisitor she ended up getting
stabbed in the stomach similar to how
she was when she was a child we actually
had hints towards this wound all the way
back in episode 3 when she ended up
getting slammed by brother 5 and she
touched it for a split second it is
possible that she had cybernetic parts
placed into it much like what we saw
with fenik shand these being stabbed
again explains how she survived the
encounter and the act is somewhat of a
means to an end-all
now this episode really wrestles with
whether she's a friend or poe and come
the end of the entry they tied things up
quite nicely without breaking the cannon
too much but does it work well we'll
talk about it later on but if you've
been enjoying the breakdowns we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up this
one last time we'll also be covering
more star wars shows later in the air so
you will subscribe
move along now with that out of the way
thanks for clicking this let's get into
episode 6. now we open on tatooine and
see two jawas as well as a blue
astromech droid that's the same unit as
r5 who would later get a bust-up
motivator on the planet motivators
actually pop up again when we discover
that the ship is struggling
motivated
here we see moisture dealers selling
water in the street and riva ends up
intervening on a guy who's just just a
bit of a jerk now this actually suddenly
hints that she's turning back to the
light as she's somewhat showing
compassion to the locals by helping them
out even if she's not specifically doing
it for their best interest she does sort
of turn towards the end of the episode
which is it set up yep i guess so no
this was a big part of the jedi order
and maybe getting that arkham asylum
death screen last week made her restart
with a new take on life now in earlier
breakdowns we talked about how riva
could likely be a play on the name revan
this was a jedi who ended up turning to
the dark side much like she did however
revan also ended up going back to the
light in the canonized ending which is
what we see happen here occur to the
devastator chasing the potters and ship
which we learn is heading to tessen i
don't believe this planet is featured in
the saga before and it's a refuge that
sadly they don't think they'll make it
to novada has of course searched near
and mustafa for obi-wan and he's
completely obsessed with taking him down
and getting his revenge of the sith he's
very much trying to use the reverse uno
card on him from their battle on
mustafar and we've seen this throughout
the show and the expanded lore episode 3
had him dragging him through the fire in
order to burn him and in the comics we
even had a section where he dreamed
about doing this on mr fall now he's so
fixated on obi-wan that he realizes
he'll leave the others alone if it means
he gets him and thus he ends up drawing
him out to a deserted planet the chase
scene feels a lot more exciting than the
dull one from the last jedi and we
actually see the struggle that they're
going through and hopelessness that they
feel however it's just the same plan as
they have in that so star wars is about
to get some
this episode is very much about obi-wan
himself intervening in order to protect
people and he really lays his life on
the line we see that obi-wan also gives
leia tall as holster and it is possible
that this is the same one she ended up
wearing in return of the jedi due to
their similar design this also popped up
in the princess leia aj rebellion comic
and it's nice that they at least kind of
tied it into that and in many ways tala
might have inspired her curta luke and
uncle owen who we learn as per usual
tidy luke mate
getting on me nerves now luke's a kid
who never hits the thumbs up button
always causes trouble and one of these
days he's gonna get his auntie and uncle
killed oh he learns about riva and we
see that and peru is played once more by
bonnie ps who also played the character
an attack of the clones and revenge of
the sith obi-wan tries to reach out to
qui-gon but he doesn't get a response
however come the end of the entry they
finally reconnect probably because the
ladder feels a bit awkward about getting
everyone to train the person who
destroyed the jedi even though they were
all like mate don't do it he's not a
good kid now the grand inquisitor really
wants vader to focus on the partisans
but as we discovered last week vader is
often blinded by the thought of victory
though he managed to sniff out riva
through doing this it was still clearly
his downfall and something that obi-wan
said would keep him as a padawan until
he overcame it this could explain why in
a new hope he says that he was but a
learner when he and obi-wan last met and
him finally dropping this makes him
become a master vader decides to face
him alone but hey you could have sent
the devastator after the partisans and
went for obi-wan yourself but never mind
now he flies in a shuttle the same
transport that we saw him riding in at
the end of empire and also at the start
of return of the jedi
on the farm luke says
i'm not afraid i know
which is of course playing on him saying
it in the empire strikes back
i'm not afraid
[Music]
yeah
you will be
vader and obi wan come face to face but
he refuses to run away like he did in
episode three and interestingly everyone
was saying that he darted for the high
ground vader says
have you come to destroy me obi-wan
potentially playing on him saying the
opposite to luke and the empire strikes
back
don't make me destroy you
yourself says
then you will die
which is a line that the character said
in rebels
then you will die similar this his mask
also gets split later on exposing some
of his face and finally showing us
hayden in the suit through this we can
hear both hayden and james earl jones
dubbing lines over each other which was
how his dialogue played out in rebels
these quotes might actually not be not
to them but hey we like go reach here at
the channel so moving on now obi-wan
ends up drawing his lightsaber and he
adopts the stands that we've seen him
take at several points in his life with
the blade up by his head whilst he
extends his other arm this has appeared
a number of times throughout the
franchise and it's sort of like poetry
they rhyme now the pair duke it out and
unlike their last fight there's no lava
here to fall into great battle of them
just going all out and it's nicely
juxtaposed by the more solitary and
stealthy scenes that are happening with
river owen actually holds his own
against her and you can kind of see why
obi-wan trusted him to raise the child
this is mirrored an obi-wan who still
holds back when fighting vader ever
since he left him to die on mustafar
he's shown that he's actually unable to
deal a full killing blow to him and this
was of course seen in episode 3 and a
new hope in which he sacrificed himself
i think he does this because deep down
he believes anakin can be redeemed and
thus he doesn't want to kill him and put
his stop to that potentially happening
obi-wan gets buried under rocks and
making them levitate is one of the first
things that a jedi learns this shows the
very base reactions to him and he ends
up burying the character lower than the
audience scores for the show on rotten
tomatoes he also calls him master which
doesn't break cannon as he refers to
himself as one in a new hope now whilst
they're fighting i thought i'd just drop
a quick correction on last week's video
we said that we thought this took place
after attack of the clones because
anakin was looking at padme's penthouse
which he wouldn't know belonged to her
unless they met or he was a crazy
stalker however due to the lightsaber
that he carries here being destroyed in
the factory and also the fact that he
still has his hand it's set either early
on an attack of the clones or just
before it still can't explain why he
looks like a 45 year old man but there
was also a hidden mickey mouse head in
the scene you can see it here and those
some of the [ __ ] had disney i'll
never forgive them
oh [ __ ]
here we go again
anyway back on the farm riva badly busts
up owen and beru which makes luke
fleeing to the desert he never actually
sees the lightsaber in the episode and
this keeps up the cannon as obi-wan had
to explain to him what one was in a new
hope later on he gets knocked out so
he's unconscious when she draws it and
this was something i theorized that they
kinda had to do in order to mess up what
would come now under the rocks obi-wan
hears lines from anakin and their
previous battle and initially it seems
that these somewhat push him into
fuelling his anger however he ends up
channeling his thoughts of luke and leia
which empowers him to finally
concentrate on the good and lift the
rocks he later builds up an array of
these that he fires like bullets lots of
flashes to the ending of last jedi here
and again this calls back to basic jedi
training in which they use their
feelings this helps him over power veda
and it leaves him breathing heavily like
how he was when he was wounded in return
of the jedi after his helmet is split
like ryan aries mum bit down too hard he
ends up denying that he's anakin obi-wan
described him as being more machine than
man now and this voice distortion and
machinery that surrounds him adds to why
the character felt this way obi-wan
apologizes for letting him down but
vader says that he killed anakin any new
hope obi-wan of course told luke that
his father was killed by darth vader and
he later explained this as being the
case from a certain point of view this
line very much adds to this notion that
it was vader who killed anakin and
unable to deal the killing blow once
more he ends up doing a craig david
[Music]
not gonna lie it did feel kind of like
fan fiction at points where they over
explain things and i think the writing
is what really let the show down now as
he leaves the planet he senses that luke
is in danger and we cut to rivers
standing over him about to strike down
however she very much sees herself in
him and refuses to deal the killing blow
once more rb1 arrives and he mentions
the tune c a location that was brought
up in a new hope riva returns with the
boy alive and it turns out that she's
redeemed herself spent several years
cutting down kids but just like how
vader murdered millions and then turned
against the emperor all is forgiven
space hitler she of course knows the
secret of luke and for some reason
obi-wan decides to take the chance of
letting her live after she drops her
lightsaber guessing she's gonna go off
and get her own spin-off show and in the
leaks it did say that she was originally
meant to be killed but that they reshot
things and now she's fine and dandy now
this idea of burying the handle in the
sand was very much seen as a way of
shutting oneself off from the force obi
wan durk his lightsaber up earlier in
the season and ray of course did it for
luke and leia at the end of rise of
skywalker excuse me there kind sir
perhaps you could spare a minute to talk
about our intergalactic lord and savior
obi-wan kenobi just saying mate yeah our
pals over at epic hero shop have a
kenobi collection going on right now
with lots of t-shirts hard prints and
more on the character not getting paid
for this yet just want to show some love
to them as they've been big supporters
of the channel and i wear this stuff a
lot and this is really the last chance
you have to get your hands on some merch
from them they've got great ones like a
lightsaber schematic t-shirt an obi-wan
stained glass window collection a nasa
space wars hoodie that has a translation
of nasa and
and lots of other stuff head over to m
chumps your punk and epic heroshop.com
that's epic hero shop.com you damn chump
see ya chump from here we go to mustafar
and get a cameo by ian mcdermott who is
once more reprising his role as
palpatine he questions whether his
feelings are clear on the matter and if
he's potentially returned to serving
obi-wan the sith were notorious for back
and front stabbing each other so him
overthrowing palps would be a big worry
this of course ended up being revealed
as his plan in empire strikes back and
just like how riva wanted to kill him
master and vader vader also wanted to
oust the emperor with his son this kind
of leads me into the next point with
palps and i also think he's probe
driving to see if he knows about his
kids avedo was completely unaware that
he had kids at this point as palpatine
told him they died along with padme it
was something that pushed him further
down the dark path he was on but he did
eventually learn that luke was his son
after the events of a new hope in the
comics we discovered that vader was
extremely curious over who had blown up
the battle station and he hired both
boba fett and black cressentine to carry
out jobs for him fett was tasked with
discovering the identity of the pilot
and after he told him the surname doth
put two and two together and figured it
all out this show keeps the info
separate from him and it also hides the
fact that leia is his child too we could
delay his home and see alda's right
instead of alders wrong
that's the worst point we've ever
dropped just unsubscribe mate i don't
even blame you i don't like heavy
spoilers anyway she gets herself ready
this time instead of the servants doing
it like how they would have in episode
one this shows her independence and she
knows how she wants to lead from now on
and as we saw in the sequel trilogy she
did become a fearless leader obi-wan
says he will help the organas again if
they need it and this would of course be
why leia reaches out to him really nice
goodbye between leia and obi-wan just a
shame she never remembers this and was
like you served my dad mate i've never
met this man in my life now obi-wan
brings up her parents and says that she
carries the best qualities of both
anakin and padme in episode 3 we did
discuss how he acknowledged the
similarities with padme but i also said
a lot of her qualities were down to
anakin too it's nice that they
acknowledged there was good in him and
this would of course lead to his
redemption back home obi-wan ends up
donning his white robes that he had in
the original and prequel trilogy later
on he puts his code over this and this
is actually what he wore in star wars
issue 15 which was centered around his
adventures on tatooine this series has
cherry-picked moments from that
including the gift he gave to luke being
destroyed by owen and also the fact that
he watched over the boy he ends up
allowing luke to grow up as a normal boy
that works 80 hours a week doing
back-breaking farm work and he implies
owen has become a powerful mentor he's
very much a jonathan kent type figure
who wants what's best for the boy but he
doesn't want to force him to become
superman at this point luke is given the
t16 toy which owen of course ended up
breaking in episode 1. this toy also
appeared in a new hope when we could see
luke playing with it during his time
with the droids in the first act there's
very much this helpful feeling to the
ending and we know from the path and
lightsabers that we saw in last week
that the jedi weren't completely wiped
out after the events of order 66. we are
yet to meet them all but the names on
the wall made it clear that several
survived and they're out there in the
galaxy obi-wan also drops a hello there
hello there
out in the desert the ghost of qui-gon
begins to form and aloha he's just kind
of mousing about now qui-gon is attached
to the living force and this is how he
was able to come back and communicate
with the jedi force ghosts were never
really in the prequel trilogy which
seemed a bit off as there were thousands
and thousands of dead jedi but
absolutely none of them reached out to
any of the others looking at the biggest
story of qui-gon he was someone that
understood that the force went past life
and death and that it existed inside
everything and everyone upon death he
came to realize that he didn't have an
individual existence and instead he just
became part of the force though he
thought this was a better kind of
existence due to the petty squabbles
that the living had he did still have
fond memories of the living world and
wished to return to it after death he
started to train his consciousness to go
back there and he managed to leave the
unity of the force in order to commune
with the living he actually guided yoder
on dagobah and helped him to gain his
own form of immortality through becoming
one with the living force in the
expanded law qui-gon initially only
existed as a voice however as he drew on
memories of his life his robes started
to form around him and eventually he
took shape appearing like the body that
he once had he says he's always been
there obi-wan just wasn't ready to see
and he will help further train him to
master his abilities and become a ghost
like he did obi-wan rides off on the
back of his eop as the twin sense of
tatooine bear down on him and this
iconography is something that we've of
course seen throughout the entire saga
title binary sunset it's something that
lucas and co used to show everything is
sort of like poetry they rhyme now luke
first looked over the sunset all the way
back in a new hope and then owen and
beru did it at the end of revenge of the
sith this was then carried out by rey at
the end of rise of skywalker and it's
used here to bring the series to a close
pretty solid episode i just felt the
writing let it down a bit but these
closing scenes really elevated it for me
lots of powerful and impactful moments
and great goodbyes to tease what will
come down the line now as for my
thoughts on the series i am kind of torn
on it in all honesty i feel there's a
lot of great moments in it but there's
also some really stupid character
choices and things that they do at
certain points in the series that knock
it down a couple of notches every
episode has had its strong points but i
feel that the true conflict of the show
should have been between vader and
obi-wan which wasn't really explored all
that in depth until episode 5. i think
the marketing team for the series knew
that that was what people wanted to see
in the show the most as well which is
why hayden and ewin were both heavily
featured in interviews for the series
their relationship the fact obi-wan is
protecting his kids and in some ways now
their father figure would have added
more interesting dynamics to it but
instead that fight it kind of feels a
bit like a footnote now i do feel that
moses ingram was a good villain and her
story was clearly given the most thought
throughout the series however even then
i feel a lot of the more interesting
things got left out and with them going
in the direction of putting her as the
main bad guy i think we should have had
more focus on her backstory it could
have showed us how she survived the
temple her training with the inquisitors
and also her turn to the dark side which
we didn't really get yet like i said i
think the focus should have been on
vader and obi-wan but considering they
didn't do that i also don't think they
really knocked it out of the park either
with who they chose to put the focus on
i also think the six episode format
disney seems to be stuck on has a lot of
issues in general and it doesn't really
give us enough time to properly explore
everything like a 10 episode tv show
would we have a pretty similar plot to a
new hope here where we're basically
getting a rescue mission on leia meeting
a scoundrel that turns out to be good
breaking into an imperial fortress to
save her escaping getting tracked by the
empire and having a big battle however
it feels like they do less than a
two-hour movie even though they have a
lot more time if you watch your tv show
like the boys and see what they do in
six episodes how many characters they
fully develop and where they take them
and then compare it to this it just
seems really simplistic now as for the
good i think ewing really nailed it in
terms of doing the old weathered out of
the game character that we've seen
become a motif in the last couple of
decades unforgiving and logan both
handled it really well and though the
last jedi failed in it i think obi-wan
was handled expertly as they shot him
growing as a character throughout it
there were also some big action set
pieces that i think worked really well
such as the fight in episode 3 and all
the scenes with vader really captured
how threatening of a villain he is i've
talked about this in depth and i think
for all the hang-ups i have with
disney's handling of star wars that
they've at least nailed their most
important character in him i also really
like tala and the inquisitors especially
brother five again i just wish that we
had more overall i think the show is
good it's just not great and for a
property like obi-wan that's what i was
hoping for for the second season
potentially in the works i'd love to see
lucasfilm take a look at what worked and
what didn't and give the show the space
it needs to develop proper storylines in
the end i don't hate what we got i just
wanted a little bit more and that's why
i get a 7 out of 10. i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are
running a competition right now giving
away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
july and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the series we pick the
comments at random on the 15th and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now so that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the boys
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over all the easter eggs in
the latest episode so definitely head
over there right after this without the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been poor i'll see you next
time take care peace